>> Tucker: THE PRESIDENT
THREATEN TO CLOSE THE
U.S.-MEXICO BORDER AND CUT AID
TO VARIOUS CENTRAL AMERICAN
COUNTRIES IN RESPONSE TO THE
MASSIVE CARAVAN OF MIGRANTS MAKE
ITS WAY SLOWLY UP TO MEXICO.
SECRETARY GENERAL JIM MATTIS
ALSO ORDERED 800 TROOPS IN
ANTICIPATION OF THEIR ARRIVAL
BUT ROBERTO HERNANDEZ IS AN
IMMIGRATION ADVOCATE IN
SAN FRANCISCO SAID THAT HE'S
HAPPY THE MIGRANTS ARE COMING.
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR COMING ON.
I DON'T EXPECT TO CONVINCE YOU
TO CHANGE YOUR VIEWS ON
IMMIGRATION.
WE'VE TALKED MANY TIMES.
I KNOW WHAT THEY ARE PAIRED BUT
I APPLAUD YOU BEING MORE HONEST
THAN MOST PEOPLE ARE SAYING
SAYING OUT LOUD WHAT YOU REALLY
WANT.
TELL ME THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
THIS GROUP COMING HERE IS THAT
IF THEY WANTED A PILE
ASYLUM, THEY
COULD APPLY.
ARE THEY CLAIMING THEY ARE
REFUGEES FLEEING A WAR?
IF SORE, WHAT WAR?
WHAT IS THE JUSTIFICATION OF
THIS?
>> GOOD EVENING.
FIRST OF ALL, LET'S GO TO OUR
HISTORY.
>> NO, LET'S NOT.
LET'S GO TO THE QUESTION.
>> LOOK AT ALL THE EUROPEANS
THAT CAME HERE -- THIS WAS A
NATIVE AMERICAN AND EUROPEANS
CAME HERE.
>> YOU'VE DEMONSTRATED A -- I
JUST WANT YOU TO ASK MY HISTORY
RIGHT NOW.
CAN WE JUST STICK TO THE
QUESTION?
WHAT IS THE JUSTIFICATION, WHAT
IS THE LEGAL JUSTIFICATION OF
THESE PEOPLE COMING TO THE
BORDER AND THAT THE
U.S. EMBASSY?
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THE ROLE OF
THE UNITED STATES IN
CENTRAL AMERICA, IN NICARAGUA,
HONDURAS, GUATEMALA, IN OTHER
COUNTRIES IN LATIN AMERICA, THE
UNITED STATES HAS PROMOTED WARS
TO PROTECT CORPORATE INTERESTS
AND
IN A LOT OF THESE COUNTRIES.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY THESE WARS
AND IT'S CAUSE POVERTY AND A LOT
OF THESE COUNTRIES.
CURRENTLY, THERE IS A POLITICAL
CLIMATE IN A LOT OF THESE
COUNTRIES AND PEOPLE ARE COMING
HERE LOOKING FOR REFUGEE --
BE ONE I'M GOING TO TRY TO TAKE
YOU SERIOUSLY --
>> THE UNITED NATIONS --
>> NOTHING THE NEW
UNITED NATIONS TO ME.
I'M TRYING TO TAKE YOU -- THE
FIRST CARAVAN IS COMING FROM
HONDURAS.
WHAT WARS ARE YOU SPECIFICALLY
TALKING ABOUT THE UNITED STATES
PROMOTED AND WHEN DID THAT WAR
AND MY?
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
SPECIFICALLY?
SPECIFICALLY
LOOK >> SPECIFICALLY LOOK AT THE
LOOK >> SPECIFICALLY LOOK AT THR
LOOK >> SPECIFICALLY LOOK AT THL
LOOK >> SPECIFICALLY LOOK AT THE
OF THE U.S. GOVERNMENT IN
HONDURAS.
>> Tucker: WHAT WAR ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT?
>> LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
DO YOU KNOW OF ANY INVOLVEMENT
IN THE U.S. IN HONDURAS?
>> Tucker: WHAT YOU ARE SAYING
YOU DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT, BUT YOU ARE
THROWING OUT --
>> YOU HAVE A SHOW JUST TO TALK
ABOUT --
>> Tucker: ROBERTO, I'M
TRYING...
I'M ASKING YOU SPECIFICALLY WHAT
WAR IN HONDURAS ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT THAT THE UNITED STATES
INSPIRED THAT JUSTIFIES THIS
MIGRANT CARAVAN?
WHEN DID THAT WAR AND MY?
WHAT YEAR?
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT OR DO
YOU NOT KNOW?
>> I DO.
LET'S LOOK AT THE ROLE OF THE
MILITARY OF THE U.S. CURRENTLY
IN HONDURAS.
>> Tucker: BUT YOU SAID THERE
IS A WAR.
SO YOU ARE TOTALLY IGNORANT OF
THE HISTORY OF HONDURAS BUT YOU
ARE LECTURING US ABOUT OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO LET THE PEOPLE
IN BECAUSE OF A WAR THAT WE
STARTED BUT YOU CAN'T TELL US
WHAT WAR OR WHAT YEAR IT ENDED?
I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING?
>> NOT ONLY THAT, BUT IT'S THE
INVOLVEMENT OF THE U.S. IN
HONDURAS AND CENTRAL AMERICA.
>> Tucker: OBVIOUSLY HISTORY
IS NOT YOUR SUBJECT.
I'M NOT --
>> UNITED NATIONS IS CURRENTLY
THE CARAVAN.
WHY WOULD THEY BE SUPPORTING AND
HELPING THE PEOPLE?
>> Tucker: I CAN'T IMAGINE WHY
THE U.N. DOES A LOT OF THINGS.
>> THE U.S. SHOULD STOP AND LET
THE PEOPLE COME HERE.
>> Tucker: LET'S SEE IF YOU
CAN ANSWER THIS.
SAN FRANCISCO HAS NOW ANNOUNCED
THAT ILLEGAL ALIENS, PEOPLE WHO
HAVE NO RIGHT TO BE HERE, WILL
BE ALLOWED TO VOTE IN LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARD ELECTIONS.
YOU LIVE IN THE CITY AND THINK
THIS IS A GREAT IDEA.
DO YOU THINK AMERICANS WHO SNEAK
INTO OTHER PEOPLES' COUNTRIES
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO VOTE IN
THEIR ELECTIONS?
>> LET'S LOOK AT HOW MANY WHITE
PEOPLE LIVE IN MEXICO.
THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT DOESN'T
HARASS THEM.
>> Tucker: ARE THEY ALLOWED TO
VOTE IN ELECTIONS?
>> LOOK HOW MANY PEOPLE DID NOT
VOTE IN THIS LAST ELECTION.
LOOK.
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
I WOULD SAY AS A PERFORMANCE
ARTIST YOU ARE TALENTED, BUT I
WANT ONE STRAIGHT ANSWER.
DO AMERICANS WHO SNEAK IN OTHER
PEOPLE'S COUNTRIES WITHOUT
PERMISSION ALLOWED -- DO THEY
HAVE A RIGHT TO VOTE IN THOSE
COUNTRIES' ELECTIONS?
DO I HAVE A RIGHT TO SNEAK INTO
MEXICO AND ANNOUNCED THAT I GET
TO VOTE THERE AND IF YOU DON'T
LET ME, YOU ARE A RAPIST?
IS THAT A HUMAN RIGHT THAT I
POSSESS?
>> IN SAN FRANCISCO, THESE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE BEING
ALLOWED TO VOTE ARE ONLY VOTING
FOR THE ELECTION, FOR THE BOARD
OF EDUCATION.
>> ANOTHER QUESTION UNANSWERED.
>> THESE PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO VOTE SPECIFICALLY FOR
THOSE WHO ARE GOING TO MAKE
POLICIES AND DECISIONS THAT
AFFECT THEIR CHILDREN.
>> Tucker: SO I GIVE YOU